♪♪
[ Electricity buzzes ]
-♪ Seth Meyers ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ He's not a liar ♪
♪ Ooh, mama, said I'm
ba-ba-back on fire ♪
-If I was a dude,
I could just be like...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This guy is swipin' right
on the whole country.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I'm Pam and I'm here
to entertain.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-There's nothing you're
gonna see in a movie
that's gonna screw you up!
-[Laughing]
-Oh, my gosh!
-When you go that hard,
you have to take a breather.
-You have to take a breather.
-I think this character and my
enjoyment in this character,
wearing a helmet
is directly equivalent
with my ambition
in this business.
-[Laughs]
-Most people be like,
"I want my face to show
in 'Star Wars'!"
I'm like, "No,
this is perfect for me."
-Yeah.
-This is exactly the level
I wanna be in "Star Wars."
-You got to work with
a up-and-comer in that scene.
-Both: Yeah.
-We basically forced her
into a hug
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
and just said thank you.
-And what do you think
the odds are
that she went directly to HR?
-I mean, because she's
a newcomer, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This is Robert Mueller
and he's like,
"My report is 400 pages long."
And then, this is William Barr
and he's like,
"Here's my summary.
It's a Post-It note."
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, this is Congress
and they're like,
"We're too busy to read it."
And then, Elizabeth Warren's
like, "Not me, bitches!"
-Oh, right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Do you have time
to keep up with politics?
Are you paying attention
to the election?
-I've paid enough attention
that I can tell this joke
or I can take a closer look!
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-To impeach a president
who 63 million people voted for
over eight lines in a call
transcript is baloney.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[as Castor]
It's, uh, ba-lo-ney!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Really loses the drama
when the word you're ramping
up to is baloney.
[ Laughter ]
You know, you never hear
a detective in a mystery
novel saying,
[French accent] "I've deduced
that the suspect's alibi is,
um, baloney!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
You are a 73-year-old man
attacking a 16-year-old activist
because she cares
about the environment.
Think about how sad that is.
You are a husk of a man.
Actually, not even. For there
to be a husk of a man,
there would've had to have
been a man to begin with.
You're a husk of a husk.
You're a Russian
nesting doll of husks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"How could you let
your 13-year-old see 'Joker'?
That's bad parenting."
And I say, "It was genius.
I enjoyed it
and my boy loved it.
Sometimes I do the wrong thing."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The first thing we went to
was Sea World
and, you know, which we now know
is a terrible place for fish,
but, at the time,
we were okay with it.
-At the time, we thought
the fish loved it.
-Oh, god, they seemed
so happy!
-My parents told me
the fish started it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This was their idea, yeah.
-Look, they're trying
to get out of the water
and walk like us.
-What does high crime mean?
High doesn't mean high
in altitude.
It doesn't mean high
on good Colorado pot.
-Sure, sure. 'Cause, most
of those, those are legal, now,
so they're not even crimes.
-[laughing] Right.
-I went outside to smoke
something legal in Colorado.
-We inhaled something there.
I forget what it's called.
We felt the effects
of that substance
and then decided,
"You know what?
We're all middle-aged.
We should start
makin' music together."
[ Laughter ]
-I wrote these for Seth.
-Yeah.
-They're in Seth's voice.
-No, they're not.
[ Laughter ]
-According to new reports,
Prince Harry
and Duchess Meghan Markle,
who are expecting their
first child this month,
are considering raising
their newborn as a vegan.
"Does that mean the [bleep]
is up for grabs?"
said the queen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You're crushin' it out here.
I love your work.
-[Laughs]
♪♪